welcome to the dave ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the dave ramsey show where america
hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life
and your money sitting in for dave i'm
dr
john dolone here with my good friend
best-selling author
podcast extraordinaire mr anthony o'neal
how are you doing good man man i'm
feeling good today it's a beautiful day
here in nashville tennessee and uh
looking forward to serving and helping
as many people as we possibly can today
outstanding all right let's go right to
the phones let's go to hunter in
washington dc
hunter what's going on how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call appreciate
it you got it man what's going on
so i'm calling my wife and i are calling
on behalf of a family member
we've been watching them make a lot of
bad financial decisions recently and we
tried to talk with them you know nicely
and gently try to
kind of guide them in the right
direction but they keep continuing to
make bad decisions and
we're getting pretty worried about them
kind of starting to realize that maybe
we need to be a little more aggressive
but we don't want to
obviously mess up that relationship
who's this family member
who's the family member sister-in-law
and her husband
so how honest do you want me to be
hunter
as honest as you should be there's not a
lot you can do man
you can't make somebody make good
decisions with their money you can
model the right way to live your life
you can have a
a kind dignified respectful
hard conversation if you will
most of the time people know that
they're not making good decisions and
more information or a lecture isn't
going to help him
what do you think anthony no i'm right
there uh with you on that one uh
jd um i think that hunter you just got
to have an honest conversation
once you have that honest conversation
you've done the very best that you can
do
move on and focus on you if you have a
family and your family you know
but i think oftentimes what we tend to
do is take on the stress
and the pain and the hurt and the
responsibility of others
rather than just focusing on ourselves
go have a honest conversation hey you're
making some unwise decisions
um i see you going down this path and
this path is leading to destruction
uh and if they hear it great if they
don't hear it cool
you've done your part but don't be over
stressed about it take care of you and
your family
and you'll be all right is that hard to
hear hunter
yeah i mean you know my wife and i are
we we've done all right for ourselves
but uh you know it's hard to watch
someone continue to make bad decisions
um
and especially it just seems like you
know you can't get through to them so
yeah it's it's heartbreaking to find out
what we
can and can't control sometimes right
especially with folks we love
and it's even harder when you know
you're gonna be responsible in some
shape form or fashion
on the back end right when it's your
parent and you know
they are burning through money anthony
and they're probably gonna having to
live with us at some point or i'm gonna
have to make a hard call
and those are challenging challenging
moments and you can do what you can do
and not hold the outcome is it really
heartbreaking
i don't know if it is for me bro it is
for me why would you say it's not
i mean because it's like if i'd done
everything within my power to to help
them
i'm not going to be hurt for something
that i cannot control
yeah i'm a more empathetic human human
than you are you are
i'm just going to be real i mean because
if i told my parents all these years hey
pay off your debt do this do that do
this do that
and then they decide not to listen why
am i
hurt by that it just i hate to see
people i love hurting
but they chose to hurt that's right so i
i i'm not hurt to see you choosing to
hurt
it's empathy yeah just that's that's my
that's that's my
you're a counselor that's why i'm i'm
just they call me i ain't gonna say that
all right let's go to jennifer in
philadelphia before i we're not gonna
get two calls out here before we get
cancelled
all right jennifer what's going on how
how can i help
hey how's it going good um so my husband
and i are both unemployed we're both
generating no income having both been
laid off
and we've recently moved from california
to the east coast and are now staying
with
family my husband just purchased a
um a small business and he wants to take
out he purchased that in cash
and he wants to take out another about
15 000
dollar small business loan and we have
about 25
000 more in credit card debt so that is
our total debt at this time
we have been living off of our 401 k so
my question is whether we should um we
have about 60
000 left in our 401k if we should take
from that
to pay off this credit card debt and the
small business loan
and then my second question is wait wait
wait wait wait let's let's just
let's let's talk about this first
question first because this first
question may not even make it to the
second well her second question was
revealing
go ahead and yeah how do you create a
budget with no income
yeah yeah it's so so so so fast
okay musa
we're taking deep meditative breaths
jennifer you know we're going to lead
with love
you know we're going to leave with love
today we're going to leave with love all
right
uh first off um thank you for calling
into the show
that's number one okay uh number two is
um let me make sure i ha let me let me
make sure i have the correct picture
here
both of you all are unemployed you move
from california to pennsylvania
which is great all right you have no
money
you went and paid cash for a business
that a business normally takes about
three years to product to start
producing
positive cash flow then you have a 401k
that you haven't transferred into
a traditional ira to set you up for your
future
now you want to take out more debt and
possibly borrow from your 401k
to establish another type of business or
to go into the business
and still neither one of you all are
working and you're living with your your
your family members is that picture
correct that i just painted
it's not as bleak as that but it's
pretty
correct except that the business that he
bought was
um a pretty nominal fee it was like
three thousand dollars and it's a um
it's like a tech um the tech support
business so he can jump in and start
making income
pretty much within the next couple of
months he's just
cleaning up the shop okay um i am
i am working i'm in travel and so
i got a gig where i'm working now but
i'm only getting paid on commission and
some of these people aren't traveling
until like 2022 so i won't see money
until then
so um so jennifer because we're running
out of time here and i want to make sure
i give you your answer here
the very first thing that you two need
to be doing is you all need to get on
the plan
okay you need to get on the plan as far
as and get a job both of you all need to
get a job
at least to start off okay now three
thousand dollars spending on a small
business
i'm okay with that but if if i would
have caught you beforehand
i would have said no you need to be
stacking all of your cash
and so that way you all can live so that
way you can take care of your four walls
you shouldn't be investing into a
company when you're living with
family right now and when you say get a
job you're talking home depot
mcdonald's yeah uber whatever right get
do what you got to do
right now so you can eventually do what
you really want to do but right now
you want to get your priorities covered
you're an emergency yeah you don't have
the you don't have the capability of
spending three thousand dollars on the
business right now
you need to be spending three thousand
dollars on yourself so you can take care
of your priorities now once you get your
priorities situated
then call back into the show holla at
john holla at myself highlight dave
highlight the personalities
and we'll help you out but right now get
your life straight
you're broke yeah you got to eat yeah
get jobs get the punch
oh i'm frustrated we're going already
two calls in
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
dalone joined
by my good friend podcast youtube
extraordinaire anthony o'neil
we're taking your calls on life money
anything that's going on triple eight
eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
so anthony you lost a you launched a
podcast
i did man and it's doing very very well
right now catching a lot of
interesting uh thoughts um this week is
as
we all know it's black history month and
so on the first week of every single
month i
take the opportunity to just bring in
some uh black people
and we talk about uh our thoughts and
our feelings on how
how do we feel as a black individual
and not everyone agrees with everything
but man i will tell you right now
uh the views the comments the
perspectives
are just insane i mean we're getting a
lot of views we're getting a lot of
attention with it so i would encourage
everyone
to to take your time to watch the black
history piano this week and come into
this with the perspective of
listening to learn not listening to
respond
so one of the important if if you were
to say
hey delaney what's one of the most
important things that's happened in your
marriage the last couple years
it was this perspective my wife and i
had when we shifted from
judgment to curiosity oh that's good
when she would say hey will you can you
help pick this up and my first thought
was
do you know how busy i am at two
tell me how that tell me how i can help
right yeah and
it was it's been a game changer for all
of us right and it goes all the way
through
that same shift from judgment to
curiosity
has helped me have political
conversations yes has helped me have
hard cultural conversations has helped
me yeah when you and i are talking
absolutely and it's helped me i mean we
all know this you all if you listen to
dave ramsey's show you heard me say this
before when i first got here man i
i really was offended by the word
redneck
ah yeah i was offended yeah and then
when i sat down and said hey
dave hey rachel hey hey jb like what
does this mean
like this doesn't mean good to me so
help me understand i was literally
listening
to learn right now not to go to war
not to come back and fight but to be
like yo in my culture where i come from
in the black community
you say redneck that's automatic racist
and i'm like when i came here and i
heard dave say that i heard something i
was like yo what
what wait but then when i listen to
learn i learn exactly what this word
actually means and i was like okay cool
great and so that's what i'm saying is
so important because you're right
once you listen to learn man you can go
into so many rooms i go into
so many rooms that i don't agree with 50
of what they're saying but i leave watch
this
smarter the way i came in because i went
into the room to listen
to have a conversation and here's my
thing if everyone thinks and agrees
uh just like you in your circle you
don't have a circle you don't have a
circle
you do not have a circle if you only
read books that you already know you're
going to agree with
yeah and if you're a republican and you
don't know any democrats you you have a
bad circle and vice versa and democrats
you know
probably because you're in a bad circle
like if if you're black and all you got
is black friends
you need a bigger circle okay we we all
need to be
challenged to be thinking outside of our
boxes because at the end of the day
my world is small your world is
small but our world combined it's
big and it's beautiful i love coming on
this show and talking with you and
talking with dave and talking with
rachel and talking with ken
and hearing different perspectives man
because it just helps me
as a man and then i can pass this down
to my kids and show them hey listen
we can do this thing together and so
that's just one thing that i really
really really love about this black
history panel was to just really
dive in and have a conversation and dave
said this on monday when he and i did
the show
yeah um you know some people may not
like it
you may not agree with everything that
they're saying but everyone has the
right to their feelings
everyone has a right to their
perspective and i think it's always fair
to just
understand how people feel you don't
have to agree
with them but it's important for me to
know john how do you feel about this
yeah and then when i hear your feelings
i'm just taking it as that that's how he
feels then later on down the road we can
come back and have a conversation
about okay hey let's talk about truth
and fact exactly
yeah but we can no one has ever we say
this all the time no one has
ever changed their mindset because they
lost an argument right yeah no no if you
go into a conversation expecting to
agree
or to argue you've you've already failed
from the very beginning well that's
because you've made the conversation
about
you've made it you've made it a
competition yes you've provided rules of
engagement instead of
hey man pass the roles have us have a
seat exactly you want sweet or unsweet
tea
yeah i'm glad you're here yeah and now
you can accomplish a lot you got to
i love it man well i'm i appreciate you
having the conversations i appreciate
you
putting the message out there if you i'm
going to repeat what anthony just said
if you are not
challenged yeah on a regular basis not
in a
where you you only watch this news
channel so you
flip it to the other one just because
you want to get your blood pressure up
not like that that's nonsense right if
you don't have people in your life that
you love
that your kids play with their kids yeah
that you share food with that you
laugh and share conversations with that
also challenge you that also say why do
you
why do you think like that that makes
sense to me at all i think it's like
this
if you don't have those people in your
life seek and find them
cultivate those friendships some of the
best conversations that have
transformed my life when i really sit
back and think about it
are those from people who do not think
like me of course one of the best
conversations i had was with
with a muslim and i totally disagree uh
with with their faith but the
conversation i was like yeah i never
i never thought about it like that and i
was able to take
some of their some of their small
nuggets and implied in my life and it
just was beneficial
when i first got here i won't say what
it was but me and dave had a
heart-to-heart conversation about
something
and i was like yo dave i never thought
about that i took some time off of work
i went home prayed thought processed the
conversation
came back and said dave you're right i'm
sorry yeah
and that's because me and dave didn't
see eye to eye on something but he
helped me to
see something clearly because i walked
in there with the open
mind that's right and i think that's so
important for
everybody wherever you are if you want
to grow
you have to have an open mind which
you're the king of that man with your
show i've been listening to yourself
like yo bro how did you get that like
how did you what like john what
how but it's like you listen and you
listen okay how is he feeling how is he
processing things
how what perspective is she coming
through on the on the dr john de loni
show
and i'm like you're great at it because
i've been like no
no but john you're like okay so how do
you feel about that
so a goal of mine is that the
the amazon the amazon marketplace
algorithm that follows me yeah yeah
can't figure it out
right that's the goal i'm ordering this
book
and that book and buying that cd and
listening to this music
yeah because i never want to feel like
i've arrived
if i'm going to continue to read
continue to grow i always want to be
having conversations here's the other
thing i just love people man that's good
and there's just a few things and when i
get to a man
people know there's a few things that i
will not move on i will not budge on
these are core deloney values yeah yeah
yeah yeah
outside of that man we're gonna figure
it out i'm confident we can figure it
out
right yeah bro i mean and i don't take
too much time on this but i think it's
important
i think i think people need to hear it
in this segment man
john let's say i called into your show
okay we're on the dave ramsey show right
now but let's flip it to the dr john
dylani show for the next
two minutes i called into your show dr
john delaney i have some friends that
some people that i that i that i like
but i don't agree with half of their
stuff and every time we get into the
room we're arguing
what should i do to go into this
relationship
and we're not arguing because we
disagree what are some key things i
should be doing
i th one i think you approach those you
approach people in your life
with dignity and respect first yes not
ideation first oh that's good does that
make sense yeah i need to write that
down and so i'm gonna sit down at a
table with folks
with one chief objective to let you know
you are seen
and you have value as a person thank you
right yes that's number one
good number two when i do that we have
anchored in
to a common place of of respect and
dignity
then i can tell you that's the stupidest
thing i ever heard in my life
right and you can hear it because you
know i don't hate you
i think that's a dumb idea and now we
can have some fun man now we can get
into some good
tussling i used to do mma i love
sparring hard yes
and then i love the high five at the end
when i know we both gave it our all
but we both went into that engagement no
one all right i respect this dude
now we're gonna let it fly there we go
when it's over it's over so
then we're gonna go get dinner man
america
find people that you disagree with love
them and then get after it
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the dave ramsey show and
we're taking your calls on life and
money
i'm john dalone my good friend anthony
o'neil let's go to jenny in charlotte
north carolina
jenny what's going on how can we help
hey gentlemen i'm big fans of you both
and anthony your interview with matthew
mcconaughey
that was awesome i loved it oh man thank
you so much
yeah hey i have a question for you guys
not technically money related but
i think you guys can help so i'm from a
divorced family my parents got divorced
when i was sick my dad was a wealthy
businessman my mom was pretty absent so
we were raised by another family
um so needless to say my relationship
with my mother is not
really close i'm 35 and have two little
girls now
and i think just disappointed in myself
this last year
um you know not sticking to things not
having self-discipline
so after the first of the year i decided
to join this free program called 75
heart and if you've heard of this
so far and um for 75 days you have to do
five things per day
one of the things is you have to pick a
diet and stick to it and no cheat meals
and no alcohol for 75 days
and so one of the i i picked a low carb
diet and also i decided to fast a couple
days a week
well the second i put that on my
instagram stories my mother
so i said i'm not gonna close with just
nailed me
via text not actually in a conversation
she lives in ohio and i'm in north
carolina and
saying this is ridiculous you're stuck
you're being crazy you're so unhealthy
i'm not coming to visit you or my
grandkids until you're off this program
just really laying into me day after day
for about four days and
i was just trying to send her the
science center some you know
good articles good youtube videos
regarding fasting
and she's kind of just trying to you
know
control me in a way but i finally i
didn't say anything rude but i finally
just said mom your concern is duly noted
she hasn't talked to me since it's been
about two weeks and i don't want to
avoid her but i feel like she's just
not mature as a grandmother as a parent
i just i just don't know where to go
from here we've had issues in the past
where i've felt like
i've been the parent and she's just
pretty immature
what would you guys say that i should do
regarding this issue
she doesn't get a vote man if you choose
to
do somersaults for 75 days in a row she
doesn't get a vote if you choose to
be vegan or quito or whatever you want
to do she didn't get a vote
and if the if your relationship with
your mom
is contingent on her agreeing with
everything that you are doing
to the point that she is going to
weaponize herself
her presence she is not going to be in
relationship with you until you're done
with this
um diet and this reset and this
practice of self-discipline so that you
can become a better mom and friend and
wife and all those things
if she weaponizes herself in that way
then she's giving you some very loud
and clear signals about the status of
your relationship
which means you have to do the hard work
of
not pursuing her approval and everything
not pursuing not catering to that sort
of
um weaponization of a relationship
and you did it right duly noted thanks
for it
if that's the case i'll see you in 76
days
and i'm moving on with my life
and listen what i just said is a lot
easier to do intellectually than it is
emotionally
i will tell you this nobody in an
emotional state
gets cured of that emotional state with
data
they get healthy through relationships
so when somebody reaches out to you and
says you're insane you're crazy how dare
you exercise every day
and change your diet and stop drinking
alcohol and do intermittent fasting and
your response is science
then you've just declared you've
responded to their declaration of war
with
guns and machine gun fire when somebody
responds to you that way you say hey
thank you so much i appreciate your
your uh your note and that's all i'm
gonna respond
helpful just it's hard because i want to
it's
i hear the silence right tell me tell me
what you're feeling when i tell you that
yeah it's just uh yeah like i said we've
had issues in the past where i don't
know if she's diagnosed
uh undiagnosed bipolar hold on hold on
jenny
jenny i don't care about any diagnosis i
don't care about any of that stuff
what my guess is for years she has
weaponized her presence
to get you to do things that she wanted
her she wanted you to do
yeah and what i want to tell you is
don't let her and her being a
grandmother
now and and i have a tear of a
four-year-old
it's just hurtful and also frustrating
she likes to make me feel like i'm crazy
that's right really frustrating
and gaslighting is the worst and you've
got to let that fantasy go
you had a picture of your mom as this
uber grandmother
more so that she was never this mom but
you had a picture of her becoming this
grandmother
and more so that your kids were going to
get to experience this incredible
grandmother relationship and it was
going to be warm and fuzzy she was going
to show up and buy him stuff and laugh
and the reality is that's not going to
happen and that hurts to
process that and to grieve that but when
you process it when you admit it when
you grieve it
then you can start healing from it and
you can un hit yourself from it you can
love your mom for who she is
and then you can go be in relationship
with folks who are going to be
affirming who are going to laugh with
you they're going to poke fun at your 75
hard but they're going to cheer you on
too
you know what i'm saying what do you
think anthony no you're hitting it right
on the head man i have nothing else to
say you're hitting it dead on the head
yeah and here's the thing man there is
no there is
there are few harder truths than finding
out your parents aren't the people that
we wanted them to be
it sucks and it's especially hard when
you have kids
and they're not going to be the
grandparents because your kids deserve a
great grandparents
right awesome grandparents connected
grandparents ones that aren't going to
suspend their love over you like that
but
it stinks me i'm sorry jenny but once
you unhook from that man
you can be free let's go to scott in
charlotte in north carolina
uh scott what's going on man oh i just
went to scott in sacramento i'm so sorry
there's a couple of scots on the board
we'll go to scott in sacramento and then
i'll circle back to scott and charlotte
what's up scott
oh man okay so i i think i just made my
wife very happy
because i just shaved my massive beard
off and i think she's
quite pleased now so i took him for the
team hey
for a guy that has been trying to i have
not shaved in 11 years and if you're
watching youtube you can see i've got no
i've i can't grow up here anthony can't
so good for you man so what's up
okay so we are my wife wants to start a
small business
selling um jewelry and
other kinds of decor items
and we are i think we just don't know
what we don't know about
starting the business and taxes so my
question is
one what do i need to figure out what do
we need to figure out for
taxes so that we don't make a mistake
and two how do we know when to put money
into the business and when you take it
out to
pay yourself and that kind of thing well
here's the thing when it comes to the
taxes you ask them to sit down with a
professional accountant that can really
nail down exactly what you need to be
doing
as far as the income have income that
you have coming
in and so it would really be hard for us
to give you the specifics because when
you ask this kind of question i want to
make sure that
we're not just answering it in a general
way we're setting you up with a pro that
can honestly sit down and tell you what
to
be doing as far as in with your taxes so
i would definitely go to daveramsey.com
look for an accountant
uh that we we endorse and sit down with
them and get that information
then number two was she said how much
money should we be investing back
into the company is that was that your
second question
uh yeah well i i know i my understanding
is that i should set up a separate
account a separate checking account for
the business
absolutely and then i know that i want
to use money we want to use money to
buy more materials and that kind of
thing i just don't know how much to put
in and how much to
say this is our profit we're going to
give put it into our
personal checking account yeah yeah so i
mean i think what you got to do is
figure out how much are you paying
yourself
all right uh what are you paying
yourself for salary uh so there's gonna
be like three questions number one is
what are you paying in the taxes you
know some people will say you need to
take 30
off top when you get when you get the
check in and then number two is what are
you paying yourself as far as the salary
and then that will determine what money
you have going back into the company to
purchase materials
and stuff like that so the very first
thing is to identify
how much money do you have coming in sit
down with an account rep
with a county executive that can sit
down tell you hey here's how much taxes
you need to be setting aside
then also decide okay great here's my
salary
and then boom here's the rest we have
going back into the company
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
deloney with anthony o'neil
we're taking your calls on life and
money at 825
5225 blinds.com find out
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
covering
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save
even more use promo code ramsey to get
the best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from
christy in georgia and anthony i
pre-read this one
i already know man christy writes
my husband and i got married last friday
we decided on separate bank accounts he
and i have both been married before and
he was burned pretty bad by his ex
i make 50 000 per year i have no idea
what he makes
but we split household bills down the
middle we both believe in your program
and are dedicated to being financially
free
but i'm not i'm just not sure if we're
going about this the right way
would you help me understand if this is
indeed 50
50. all paper rock scissors are you to
see who goes first anthony
hey i already talked about being
empathetic so
why don't you go anthony uh
straightforward answer no you're not
going about this the right way
a couple should not have two separate
bank accounts
a couple should not know will should not
be in a position to where they do not
know what the other person is making
how is that you're married and you do
not know
how much money your husband makes but
you just
know that you all split half of the
bills so i'm going to play devil's
advocate because oh no we ain't got time
for devil's ad no no because i'm i'm
pretending i'm driving down the street
somebody just responded uh-uh i got
burned
and i'm not doing that again okay you
got burned
heal move on if you want to do it the
right way you got to do it the right way
okay well how can two become one
in a marriage when everything is still
two you you didn't become one
y'all just roommates okay studies are
showing that when you come together and
you genuinely come in together and say
you know we're gonna do this together
have a clear conversation hey i was
burned i was i was
i had some issues cool you should have
talked about in beginning the marriage
y'all maybe should have did a prenup
okay i mean there's so many different
things that you can do but you cannot be
married and not know what your husband
is making and not know what your wife is
making
not really have a joint conversation
every month saying hey
here's how much money we have here's how
we're going to build wealth here's how
we're going to live a legacy what you're
going to say hey
make sure you put 50 set aside for
school no
you're a married couple and you're over
here saying you do this i do this no
it's
we do this when two or three gather he
didn't say when one
when two or three come in the midst
there's power when there is
unity there's no power when it's
separate
there's power when there's unity so no
you're doing it the wrong way
now you could be soft and i am say your
stuff
bro i was gonna i was coming back harder
but i won't even do that
i'm a thousand percent here's the thing
if you were hurt before in a previous
relationship
and you are hurt in a way that is that
hurt is ongoing don't get married
you have no business getting married to
somebody else
if you are not fully all in on this new
marriage
right so i know you got burned pretty
bad
and i'm sorry that you got burned pretty
i hate that for you yeah then don't get
married
because the solution is not to hitch
yourself to somebody
sorta right it's not to anchor you don't
want to you know
you uh you do a bungee jump right
and uh man you got scared on that bungee
jump you got hurt on that bungee jump
they didn't wrap it on right or whatever
if you decide to get back up there and
jump again
you can't have a secret little leash
where you tie yourself to the to the
bridge because you're gonna break your
back
right if you're gonna get back up there
and jump you gotta get back up there and
jump
christy you all both need to sit down
asap
put all your cards on the table here's
how much money we have here's how much
money i make we're going to get
one checking account we're going to work
on this together
we're going to heal together he needs to
be honest about how much he's hurt and
then y'all got to work
yeah y'all got to come together on this
deal um look at you and me agreeing
anthony it's a new day in america
all right let's go to scott in charlotte
north carolina they're right scott
what's going on brother how can we help
not much how you gentlemen doing today
outstanding man
so what's up glad glad to hear it well
so um you got your pins ready always
for you always okay good deal good deal
so started a business about two years
ago um
ended up selling it about a month ago
and that company that bought
my company actually gave me a job so i'm
working for them now
household income is about
80 right now should be moving up to 110
next year
no car payments no credit cards um
we have 58 000 on our house
we have a student loan of 61 000 and i
have 70 000
from the sale of the company and working
the baby steps would i not take a look
say it again you got 58 000 what scott
morgan mortgage mortgage yeah and i have
uh
70 000 cash that's including emergencies
right
cash and how many student loans
one and it's 61.
geez you have wow
okay what's the business scott
i'm i own a tree service i've cut trees
for a long time
doing it part time and anybody calls me
i would say do your business part time
before you jump in full time there you
go
you know a word to the wise and don't
take anything out you don't have to
until you're making money i love it um
so we just dumped everything back into
it and two years later
got an offer on it um and
they paid me well for it very cool so
how can we help man
my question is if i work the debt
snowball my house is actually less than
student loans
absolutely so i could write a check
today i'm going to take my house off no
but i'm still asked what 61 000 student
loans
right yeah so baby step 2 is pay off all
of your debt excluding your mortgage
okay yes excluding your mortgage because
your house is actually
generating money for you so we don't
mind that sitting there for a little
while longer
while you eliminate the student these
student loans now i'm pretty sure these
are all federal are any of these private
oh no they're all good i believe they're
all federal all right so right now you
want to attack these student loans
because you don't you're not
accumulating any interest right now
because the government has pushed that
off for a little bit of time so your
best bet
is to go ahead and get rid of this 61k
if you have
70 000 cash i'm hanging up the phone
from us within the next 30 seconds
and i'm cutting a check for 61k to pay
off
this then now you are extremely debt
free
you still have 9 000 an emergency fund
you're making eighty thousand dollars a
year right now and then boom i'm gonna
get back and build up
of three months three to six months in
my emergency fund
i'm gonna start investing and then i'm
gonna attack that mortgage okay
but okay can i ask you one more thing
something
okay appreciate it i'm 37 my wife is 33.
okay uh both in good solid careers and
we have
80k and 401k no don't
we need to stop investing but do you
think we are on track to
get to the point where we will happen so
so let me let me tell you this are you
behind right now yes
okay i'm 36 years old and i have more
money in my account with that
but just because you actually you and i
are behind i'm gonna be real with you
i'm gonna be reeling dave ramsey show
i didn't start investing until i got out
of debt okay but here's the thing one of
our good friends chris hogan says
age is not a a a a number it's a re it's
like it's a
well no he says it's not an age number
yeah retirement's not an age it's a
financial number
so for you is once you get 100 debt free
what i want you to do is go to
chrishogan360.com
and then just start just getting all his
content
because once you become debt-free in
your 30s you are
ahead of the game and then now you're
going to start investing 15
you and i both are not just going to
catch up we're going to surpass
our age bracket when we get into the 50s
so trust me
get this 61k paid off you got 70k cash
pay that student loans off get your
three to six months back up and running
then you need to go over there and rock
with chris hogan so you can learn how to
get is 15
invested asap okay max out your 401ks
max out your roth iras and i guarantee
you you'll be an everyday millionaire
within the next 10 to 15 years
it's been a great hour i want i want him
to pay off his debts and then call us
back in another hour and do the
debt-free scream that's how awesome
today is going to be
we've got an hour in the books we got
more to come stay with us this has been
the dave ramsey show hmm
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
[Music]
story
from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money sit again
for dave i'm john deloney joined with my
good friend and best-selling author
anthony o'neil we are taking your calls
on life
and money and everything in between
anthony how are we doing
i'm doing well man excellent excellent
excellent
let's go you know what before we go to
the phones
anthony how's your podcast doing my man
it's doing great bro
who you funny right now
i mean it's doing good man i'm grateful
for um
uh just everything that it's doing man
so we can talk about it man i want to
get to the phone lines let's go there
all right all right let's go to shanley
in honolulu hawaii
shanley how are we doing hello friday
and also with you doing good good good
good how can we help
um okay uh real quick just a little
background my husband and i
um were married i am from four months
pregnant with my first
child or our first child um we haven't
started the baby steps yet
for dave ramsey so we're not on the
program just yet but i follow
dave ramsey on instagram i watch his
videos and
so i have like the general knowledge of
his program um
my husband and i we we do agree on one
thing that we
we need to get out of debt and amen to
you you guys earlier with um
the christie answer to christy about we
share our debt
and we share our income so good for you
we agree on that too
yeah but um we also just come from
different backgrounds so we kind of
see money differently and we spend it
differently and have different ideas of
how we save it as well
but we we know we need to get out of
debt like
as soon as possible um so i was trying
to think like you guys and get all my
questions answered thinking like dave
and chris hogan and
all you guys and the only question i not
only but
kind of one of the big things that stood
out that i need help with
before we get started in the program is
my husband
um he resells shoes so he's like in the
shoe game
kind of hacking i don't know if you guys
know what that is absolutely
what that is yeah he's on the app it's
also a hobby like he loves to do it
he loves shoes nike shoes adidas all
that
but he likes to buy and resell them um
he uses credit cards often and i know
dave ramsey program is is anti-credit
cards
i'm a little more pro debit card or
checking account i feel better using
money i know i have
um but he he likes to use the credit
cards because he gets cash back as well
you know we we have like rocket 10 we
get cash back
um but i just don't know how his shoes
like reselling fits
into the program if we did get started
and we just have a lot of debt that i'm
like we i just need to get started
already
before we have a child and just more
debt and all of that
yeah um you're absolutely right and i
would love to have a conversation with
your husband um i wish he was there
um is he there yeah he is yeah put him
right next to me yeah put him on put his
beautiful phone he made you call
come on man well i'm the one that's like
i want to do the program yeah he's not
anti
dave ramsey but he's also like he wants
to understand it and have a clear path
before we get started that's good yeah
i'm not going to talk to him about the
shoes i want to talk to both of y'all
put them on speakerphone
let me know let me know when y'all on
speakerphone okay we're on speakers
okay what's up's last name uh last name
is angel
samoan so i'm i'm just gonna say brother
and sister then for right now all right
here's the thing man i'm not even gonna
talk to you about your business i want
to talk to you about youtube being on
one accord okay
i think that youtube if you're gonna say
hey we're gonna get out of debt
you can't build debt if you're racking
up
other debt okay you can't you can't get
out of credit card debt you can't get
out of build debt
if you're racking up other debt even for
the business
so i think before we can address the
business side of things bro
i think you and your wife need to get on
the same page bae
is our end goal to be 100
debt free if that's our end goal
then we both on both sides are going to
work towards that end goal
and that end goal means we can't have
credit cards because we want credit card
points
and we want reward points because what's
going to happen bro
let me be real with you as a brother to
brother
okay something's gonna come up that's
not an emergency what you're gonna do is
put it on the credit card
because it's convenient so what i want
you to do
um is before you cut up anything because
this ain't about cutting up
i want you and your wife to get on the
same page
when you two get on the same page then
backtrack that all right
what are the steps we need to be doing
to get to
that goal and if that goal is to be 100
debt free you need to cut up all your
credit cards still run your business
because i know you can make money
flipping shoes i'm with you in that part
but how do we cash flow that
and build cash from there you know so i
i would
i'm not coming for you because you're
the man of the house i respect the king
of the house
i'm just saying yeah yeah yeah as the
king of the house
just make sure that you and the queen
come together on the same message and
y'all go after the same goals man
so here's what i'm gonna do for you okay
i'm going to
give you two things one because i like
giving away my stuff and two because i
like giving away other people's stuff
just don't give away my stuff i'm not
gonna give away anthony stuff
i'm not gonna do that he charges me for
it guys it's just the way he
wrote okay all right so the first thing
is when's your baby do
july july all right oh yes
so i'm gonna give you guys a ticket to
the digital date night the money and
marriage event that's coming up with me
and my good friend rachel cruz dave
ramsey's daughter on february 12th
and we're going to send you a it's
you're going to be able to have this
date on your own couch you're going to
prop your feet up and we are going to
walk you through some things that are
challenging
couples and marriages across across the
world right now
the last year and a half has been a zoo
and
how y'all can come together practically
with your money right now
and the second thing i'm gonna give you
because i love you and i've got faith in
you
are you all in thank you yeah tell me
you're all in
all right i'm going to give you a year
subscription a whole year
a year subscription are you good today
to ramsey plus
which is all of the financial peace
university
all of the videos y'all gonna watch them
together you're not gonna just sit there
you're gonna do it together
and it's gonna be come with a year's uh
uh subscription to the every dollar app
so y'all can be together in your
finances
no hiding no cheating no nothing you're
going to be together and listen
you're going to work real hard together
coming together you're going to build a
marriage that no one around you has
you're going to be the light on a hill
for your friends who are married and
that baby is going to come into a
marriage
of peace where y'all get to laugh you
all get to play you'll get to be silly
and you're not gonna be pacing the
the floors every night wondering how
we're gonna pay our bills
okay are you all in amen thank you so
much
we're all in i want to be that person
with the board that says and we're
debt-free
with our money and there's two thank you
two people between you and that goal
and it's you all too okay those
decisions
start together they start united and
they start
today see couples like that you hear
them oh yeah let's go
what huh yeah i want to be that person
that's
who we want calling in to the dave
ramsey show
um i'm we a whole family tree is about
to be different glad to be because these
two are going to stand up and do it
different i'm proud of them
you have a good heart john huh you have
a good heart man i just like giving away
dave's stuff
i see triple eight
two five five two two five give us a
shout this is the dave ramsey
show
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
chministries.org
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
dolone with my good friend anthony
o'neil
give us a shout at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
it's triple eight eight two five five
two two five talking about
life and money when it comes to making
big life changes like buying a home
getting married having a baby the last
thing on your mind is making sure
you have drum roll please the right
insurance coverage
i get it big changes are overwhelming
but what would be even more overwhelming
is to find yourself in debt
because you and your family weren't
properly covered
if not having the time or energy is
what's keeping you from getting the
right insurance
coverage use one of our endorsed local
provider
or elp insurance agents to help elps are
independent agents who find you the best
coverage at the best
price free of charge that's right
an independent agent shops a variety of
insurance options
finds you the best and explains all the
technical lingo so you know exactly what
you're getting
for free
text insurance to 33789 to get connected
with an elp
and let a pro help you find the coverage
that fits
your life that's insurance to three
three
seven eight nine all right let's go to
jonah in pittsburgh pennsylvania
jonah what's going on how can i help
thank you for taking the call um can you
hear me
absolutely man what's going on perfect
perfect
so i am receiving um about twenty
thousand dollars from my grandmother
uh yesterday thankfully she has been
studying for me
since i was born so very grateful for
that
um right now i have about
three hundred dollars in credit card
debt um
and then uh so i've actually
i've grown a portfolio about a hundred
people
but i've kind of done it in a way that
i'm not too proud of i actually don't
have any emergency funds right now
um so all of my cash i don't have any
cash actually
so i wanna my goal is especially to be
financially free
uh and i wanna i wanna make sure i do
this right um because i don't
necessarily
have the most uh job security
so i'm trying to kind of do what i can
with what i have
how old are you i'm 25 in march
okay 25 years old okay you're getting
inherited
you have a fiance as well
okay and you have a son um as well
all right sounds good so you're 25
you're about to get married you have one
son
and you are uh three thousand dollars in
debt and i think you said you built a
portfolio of how much
uh if that seems now okay cool
and then you have a twenty thousand
dollar check coming in okay so i'm not
really worried about the inheritance
check right now
i want to talk to you about what are you
doing as far as in creating a solid
foundation for you what are you doing as
far as in a career right now at 25
so currently i'm having a nine-time job
i graduated with a pharmacy degree um
i'm working
towards going to grad school um with
that specifically i would like to
teach as a professor um aside from that
um you know i've been applying actually
for a couple years and
i've had no luck okay so far but um
so in the meantime we are here um i'm
actually
in in morgantown virginia we are trying
to
set up a community resource center here
focused on
arts and kind of operate as cooperative
for creators and all sorts of
people and just providing opportunities
to gotcha
okay cool great here's the very first
thing i will tell you man
when you get this inheritance check i
will go ahead and pay off all your
credit card debt all right
um and then when it comes to your uh
your portfolio that you're building
you're not really in a place yet to be
to be investing
uh because you don't have a job a stable
job right now and so for me
i will be focused on getting you a
stable job with stable income
especially with you about to be a the
provider for a family you have a wife
and a kid
uh that's about to you know be moved
about to move in with you
uh man i i'm looking for a job and and
i'm even looking at okay is school right
for me right now
okay that's the kind of questions that
i'm asking myself i'm
what i'm doing is i'm stepping back and
i'm looking at
the next 20 years of my life where do i
want to be
when i turn 45 years old and how do i
get there do i want to be a good father
do i want to be a good wife
i'm not a good i have a good father and
a good husband
do i want to have a solid job and once
you answer all these questions
then john he needs to work backwards
right now i mean but you got this 20 000
that's great pay off your debt then what
i would do is set aside the rest of that
money so you can cash flow
your wedding uh that you have coming up
and honestly
man i i'm i'm not spending no more than
two to three thousand dollars for my
wedding this is a
you don't have the money yeah big
wedding yeah knock it out get it done
you need an emergency fund you got a
little one
you got to have some cash in the bank
and then like anthony said you got to
start hustling
i know you have a dream of being a
professor that's a hard job these days
they're getting
rare and rarer to come by what i don't
want you to do is go to grad school with
this
dream that's gonna come true seven years
from now get
one job two job three jobs and start
socking some money away man
good stuff good deal let's go to andrew
in houston andrew how can i help man
hey thanks for having me um so a quick
backstory
um been a huge fan of you all y'alls for
a while now
um took the uh the debt-free freedom
class
nine years ago got married nine years
ago i was making 15
an hour didn't know anything about money
and after i took that class i started
working towards just understanding money
and
now nine years later i'm making over a
hundred thousand dollars a year um
my house is paid off my cars are paid
off
way to go man it's been a journey but
got there now you know my question is
i've got 80 grand in the bank
um i don't want to buy a new car i feel
like that's a waste of money at this
point in my life
i want to invest i'm thinking real
estate i'm trying to stay away from
stocks but i wanted to hear from you
guys see what you thought
yeah talk to us man what do you have
invested right now are you doing like a
401k
i don't have a 401k i do have company
stocks
uh that best every year okay um but no
nothing nothing other than that do you
have a roth ira
i do not okay cool so that's where we're
gonna start that's gonna be the
foundation
um you have eighty thousand dollars in a
bank what i'm gonna do i'm gonna hang up
the phone for myself
i'm going to call um a smartvestor pro
i'm gonna let them know that hey i want
to invest now before we ask this
80 000 in the bank your household income
is about 100 so that means you need
about 25k
uh for an emergency fund all right so
we're going to take that at 60 so you're
going to have 55
000 that you can invest
all right what i'm going to do here is
the very first thing i'm going to go
into my office tomorrow
i'm going to say hey if i can start
opening up investing into a 401k
do y'all do y'all have a traditional or
roth 401k there
uh i haven't even looked into it to be
honest with you i'm not sure
cool that's what i'm gonna look into i'm
gonna look in and see um if they have it
so when it comes to investing there's
three things uh
andrew number one is gonna be a match we
look for how we can get the match number
two is gonna be a raw
number three is gonna be traditional
okay so if your company has a match i
want you to invest
up until that match then you're gonna
come go over and invest into a roth ira
okay so as soon as you hang up the phone
you have 55 000
that you can invest call an investor let
the investor know hey
i got money cash money real money 55 000
in real cash money that i want to invest
what should i do the very first thing on
the investment tool is a roth ira
make sure that they uh get invested into
a growth stock mutual fund
and then you can open up other mutual
funds or you can leave that there
and then stack that money to now get
into real estate
but right now you want compound interest
working into your favor
once you have that all situated then yes
we can start looking into real estate we
can start looking into land
uh but right now let's do the foundation
so you know for sure you have some
compound interest and matches working on
your side
then you can call us back and i would
say call back and holla at dave
because dave is the king when it comes
to real estate man and andrew
i heard it in your voice you're right
it's not sexy
there's not gonna be fireworks it's not
as cool as going to
buy a rent house or taking out a
mortgage on a rent house
slow and steady you've done it over nine
years now you are making a phone call
that says
i've got no mortgage and 80 grand in the
bank
you're doing things that nobody does
keep taking the small
steps the tortoise wins every time yeah
good for you andrew triple eight eight
two five five two two five give us a
shout this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm john
deloney with my good friend anthony
o'neal
and i'm excited that there are two
beautiful people standing on the debt
free stage
here in the lobby of ramsay solutions
david and sonya from
fond du lac wisconsin how are we doing
we're doing great
we are good we're glad to be here so you
are debt free
we are correct outstanding all right so
how much have you paid off
we paid off a hundred and thirty two
thousand one hundred and thirty one
dollars
in five years in one month five years oh
you this is a grinding one right
yep y'all grounded what was your range
of income during this time uh we started
off at 62 000 and we ended at 150 000.
why the jump how did you do that um
changing jobs and then she was out of
the work first
workforce for a few years with our three
kids at home
and then she got back into the workforce
again so david was this 132 131 was that
student loans
uh that was student loans medical car
and our house
you paid off your
are house weirdos fantastic
how old are you two i am 34. i just
turned 33 this week
y'all are millennials yes
yes see dave should be here today
tell me why because you know he needs to
see millennials doing this
nope we're going to take it all for
ourselves this is awesome david and
sonia all right so
take me back five plus years ago
something rattled the cage that set you
on this journey what was it
um we took fbu uh september
2014 at that time we had a six-month-old
and we had 18 month old we had two kids
12 months apart so we had two kids in
diapers
we had one on formula the fact that you
can remember a date from that time
oh yes it was crazy times okay so at
that time i was teaching
david was working at a different job at
the time
i was working uh as a cnc programmer
wow excellent i think you're gonna say
cnc music factory okay so then what
happened
um it's just was one of those things
where i think every time i came home
from target i think his blood pressure
went up a little bit more every time
and quite honestly i wasn't spending
crazy money on foolish things like i was
paying for diapers and i was paying for
formula
and you know laundry detergent things
like that and
he was just like i mean he was just
stressed out and i didn't like to see
him that way and
he kind of brought it to my attention
he's like i think we should do this
class and i'm like
what do you mean like what kind of class
are you talking about and he's like
oh it's called financial peace
university and i'm like oh and he was
kind of
discussing it and he was like there's
one actually in our area
and you know it'd be once a week you
know for eight weeks they had like child
care included
so like we could drop the kids i'm all
in i know i was
super excited it was very helpful
because yeah we had two young kids at
the time
so who introduced you to the program um
i actually found dave
on the radio when i was traveling back
and forth from my
technical school okay okay so so put me
in
your driving yes you start imagining
this conversation that you're gonna
bring up
to a working mother of two
half people and you're thinking all
right how am i going to do this how am i
going to do this
walk me through that moment of courage
when you said hey what if you
what about this um i
i do not remember that what's blacked
out well so long ago played
excellent so what was the key thing to
getting
out of debt i mean because this is a lot
of money that you all paid off
and it was a long time it was
it was um like i said when we first
started we had the two kids
um i was a teacher for a couple years
um i went down to part time and then we
found out we were expecting again
so we at that time i was teaching
part-time
and we knew when our third child came
along is like you know was it really a
point of me working when we were gonna
have three kids under the age of three
in daycare so that was the time when i
decided to step away from teaching and
to stay home and it was very much an
adjustment
very much where i love teaching i love
children
but it was just one of those factors
where something just had to give so i
did i stayed home for probably
three four years four years um
and yeah um yeah because it was
helpful for us that um our that we had
about 30 000 worth of just
um non-mortgage that that after we had
our third son
or our third kid um we were able to pay
off that debt completely at that point
so awesome
yeah so that was the beginning of
october uh 2015 that we were
debt-free and for a while we were just
kind of
you know going along going along and
then
like my income started kept kept growing
and
i'm like what do you think about trying
to pay off the house
pretty quickly here and i have to give
her a lot of credit like the last year
she was
anything and anything we were just gonna
throw up the debt we're throwing at the
house we're throwing at the house
non-stop
i think every time like he came home and
he's like oh were you coloring on our
chart again i'm like yeah i just threw
another five thousand dollars at the
debt and he'd be like
oh it helps that david does not spend
literally any money like he's just
very like yeah he's like he doesn't need
anything he's very
yeah yeah so how old are your kids now
um our oldest just turned eight this
week um
our daughter will be seven in a week or
two
yeah and then we have a five-year-old so
tell me tell everybody in
in just one sentence you've changed the
entire trajectory of their childhood
they're not going to know that stress
they're not going to know that
gritting teeth moment that what does
that mean to you
i mean it's awesome when we were doing
this you know they were little they had
no idea
what they were missing out on and
honestly i really don't think they were
missing out on anything you know
i felt like we were very normal
like i don't feel like we were you know
we just think about anything very
extravagant or anything yeah
i mean we just we live pretty simple
lives we're not very extravagant
um you know some of our friends and
were kind of following us you know as we
were paying off our house
and um they're like i just feel like
you're like normal people
like you you're not hey you're you're
not
well anymore right you're not normally
poor david
insonya from fond du lac wisconsin paid
off a hundred and thirty two
thousand dollars in five years making 62
to 150
000 with three kids
count it down for us three three two
one we're dead free
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony have you ever
grinded something out i don't even grind
it out as the right word
for five years to change everything
i mean i have but to hear other people
do that specifically for them
you know in the process of raising three
small kids uh
she wasn't working and they was like yo
we're just gonna go gazelle intense and
i love how
they kept the same gazelle intents from
paying off their consumer debt and flip
that over to their mortgage
and so now that it's a young couple
younger than you and i
yeah do not have a mortgage payment so
when they wake up and they see their
kids
and their kids say mom and dad can we go
to disney world they can say yes
and if they're saying no it's just
because they don't want to go not
because they can't afford it
so all the they said so many things that
are
different and counter-cultural they said
things like we're just simple people and
we like
hanging out with each other yeah we just
decided to pay our house off
we just decided i'm gonna stay at home
because i want to
right right all these options and
choices they made that fly in the face
of
you can only be happy if you have more
crap the more stuff you own the happier
you are
right the bigger the house the more the
more the more and they just said uh-uh
listen this man they started off making
sixty-two thousand dollars
that's a lot of money to some but that's
really not a lot of money right okay
and they say you know what we're just
gonna be good stewards of the resources
that we have right now
and we're going to attack this debt and
i believe it's because they were good
stewards
with this little bit just the spiritual
side of me saying this god trusted them
with more
and look flipped their money not just
flipped it but doubled it to 150.
changing their whole trajectory of their
family tree and i loved what you said
your friends are starting to say huh you
don't look like people who have a paid
off house y'all are just regular old
folks
yeah started on the bottom now they dead
free on top
and we think paying off your house comes
from scratching a ticket
or from money falling off a tree it just
comes from hard work day after
day after day you two dave and sonya are
free congratulations inspiring millions
right here
on the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show aaa
825-5225
let's go to josh in tyler texas josh
what's going on man
hey john hey anthony how you guys doing
good how can we help man
uh i am in a i'm not sure in a
pretty unique financial situation a
blessing
um but we're on step three e we're
saving up for a down payment
on a house very cool my wife's a teacher
but
my end is the unique part um i am a
i'm a youth minister at a church but we
like i'm getting my master's program and
the program
my master's degree in the program that
pays for my master's degree
is also paying for our housing okay all
right so we were going to go to the
traditional
um uh manual underwriting ways but we
have no rental history in fact we only
have two bills
um and so our qu my question is really
should i be still trying to get
a manual underwriting way to go about
getting a house
yes or just have credit cards no
gas only no no no no no no no no no no
no uh and josh i want to definitely
thank you for doing ministry man i know
exactly
where you are and where you're coming
from uh because i
before joining the speakers group here i
was a full-time
minister as well within the gospel and i
had the exact
opportunity the same opportunity as you
uh to where i could um
i had housing i had a housing allowance
and so for you right now the main thing
is to yes reach out to churchill
mortgage uh and just tell them your
situation
um and yes they will help you get a
home mortgage okay um and so what what i
would recommend
is um how much money do you have down to
go towards a house right now
well it's this is we're trying to figure
out what to do for the next year and a
half i'm in this program for a year and
a
half
longer and we will have um i think we're
looking at thirty thousand for a down
payment for uh
uh more than twenty five percent down
payment per half so you're gonna have
thirty thousand dollars
in texas oh yeah that's good so you can
get you a nice little
a home out there for about two hundred
thousand two twenty five two fifty if
you want to stretch
it and that's a beautiful home in texas
you know i'm kind of jealous of the
homes in texas you know because
y'all can get a five six thousand square
foot home for for you know a quarter of
a meal
and that out here will cost us a million
and so um i think that's a great route
30 thousand dollars and
while what you're doing right now is i
will go ahead and call churchill
mortgage
and just start building that
relationship with them tell them hey
my time frame is about a year and a half
uh go ahead and allow them to pull your
foul and let them coach you on what
you need to be doing but right now uh
just be renting
and just pay off your stuff um and just
pay your light bills your utility bills
on time keep track of that
and you're going to be all right man
trust me i did that um and
it was it was perfectly fine all right
josh you married
i am it's just me my wife how long have
you all been married
we have been married oh gosh almost two
years yeah that's a number you got to
know off top of your head man
yeah right all right so here's what i'm
going to do
we've got a february 12th at 7 p.m
money and marriage live stream with me
and my good friend rachel cruz
i'm going to give you a free ticket to
this event that way you can have a date
at home you don't have to go anywhere
y'all can
dream about what this home is going to
look like that y'all are going to buy
you can learn a couple of tips on how to
stay married
and connected in this madness season
that we're in
and you can also learn how to deal with
your money together
so hang on the line and kelly will get
you hooked up all right let's go to
jack in charleston south carolina jack
what's going on
hey guys uh thanks for having me on the
show good to talk to you
you too man thanks for calling what's up
yeah
all right um it's just sort of a general
question i wanted to bounce off of you
um you know my wife and i we owe
about 418 000 on our mortgage
okay um but we have a rate a really nice
rate at 2.375
for 15 years we just refinanced okay
um we don't have a ton of debt
besides the mortgage what's not to have
hey jack what's not what's not a lot of
money
like how much that do you have sorry
yeah how much debt do you have
uh the mortgage 418 000.
okay so that's it you don't have any
consumer debt
well you know just we pay up our credit
cards every month but there's nothing
we we have all of our cars paid off um
we have two kids in college and uh
they're pretty much paid off um you know
with their 529 plans so
all that's um cool in pretty good shape
all right so my question is
um we have this joint investment account
which is basically just a bunch of
mutual funds that are
you know helped run by our financial
advisor and we have
770 000 in that account okay
so my question is you know we're making
decent money on that you know
it could be eight to fifteen percent
just depends on the year
is it worth it to drain that account and
pay off the mortgage where our mortgage
rate is
is only at you know two and three seven
five
uh let me ask you this question do you
have what what's your retirement
situation look like looking like any
401ks any roth iras
what's your retirement fund okay give me
those uh
yeah we have uh 401ks my wife and i and
we also have a um
uh roth ira and the total amount is
about 2.5 million
2.5 million in both those
combined and then you have a four
hundred and eight thousand dollar uh
mortgage
and you say you have no consumer debt
and then you outside of what's your
savings account looking like right now
as far as an emergency fund
you pretty good in that area yeah
so you know um you know we have
probably about 70 or 80 000
you know in savings or money that we can
get to pretty quick without
taking any capital gains uh you know
hits great so what i do is like right
now
um i am actually stacking money in the
mutual funds right now to go ahead and
build my dream house in the next couple
of years
um after i get married and so when i
find my house right
i'm gonna withdraw from my mutual funds
and i'm going to pay cash
uh for my dream home so in this
situation which you're already having
2.5
million dollars in your retirement funds
you already have a fully funded
invested fund yeah i would say go ahead
and pay off your mortgage today
all of it and i still want to leave you
with another 200 something thousand
dollars inside of
your mutual funds what i would do is
i'll just hop on there and maybe look
into
um if you want to i would probably
looking to buy maybe some more real
estate and some more property
to start creating another stream of cash
flow for you but to answer your direct
question
because you are following the baby steps
and this mutual fund
america who's listening right now you're
probably saying wait i thought you
shouldn't withdraw
funds from your mutual funds no there's
two different kinds you have one that's
covered from retirement which is a roth
then you have regular mutual funds such
as this is sitting there
you can withdraw for that because you're
not withdrawing from your
retirement so i will go ahead and pay
off your mortgage and then look into
investing
that uh the rest of it as well uh jack
such a great question man
you and your wife are doing some
extremely extremely
good stuff right now with your finances
all right let's run to rodney in new
york hey rodney we're up against the
clock get right to your question man
what's going on
hi john good afternoon anthony two um
my question for you guys is my parents
sat me down
last week and told me that there's some
money that i'm gonna be
taking over when i turn 25
later this year but they've already
started to throw hints around
what i should be doing with it and you
know over the past few years as i
started working i've worked
hard i think to set boundaries with my
parents around
you know what i'll be doing with my
money and and
and what what what freedom i'd like to
have in making those decisions
so where's this money come from is it a
is it a trust is it inheritance what's
it from
it's it's money that they have set aside
for me and put
you know in just investments from when i
was a kid and i just never knew about it
so my guess is they want to give you
some money and
this is going to you're going to become
a marionette is that correct
i'm not sure what a marionette is it's a
it's a puppet that's
operated by strings
um that's kind of what it seems
like yes so here's the deal if you take
money from somebody
and they they want to tell you how to
spend it
it's their money right so i'm gonna be
very very careful anthony i know what
you i'm gonna be very careful before i
accept money
from other people or i'm gonna have my
own
i'm gonna say once it's mine this is
mine and if people wanna hold it over me
i'm gonna say
thanks but no thanks this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car
rental studio this is the dave ramsey
show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money
and your life i'm dr john dolone here
with best-selling author and good friend
anthony o'neil
host of the table with anthony o'neil
world-class youtube and podcast and we
are here to take
calls on anything going on in your
hearts and your minds in your home
struggling with the person you see in
the mirror
your kids your family your money
anything give us a shout
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all right let's go to lucas in
providence rhode island lucas
how are we doing what can we do to help
i'm doing good thanks for having me on
you bet what's going on um so i'm a
freshman engineering student
at uri and i'm planning on working a lot
you know over the summer making a lot of
money and i should be able to graduate
debt-free you know not gonna have a lot
of money after but i should be able to
graduate
pretty much debt-free but i'm wondering
if i should take out a student loan
anyways just because it's looking like
there might be some sort of
relief bill going through government so
i don't know
where you guys thoughts are on that oh
you want to try to take out a loan and
catch the see if you can get a
year or two paid off for free so what
you're trying to just kind of back in
scam the system
yeah because it's like um
i should be able to graduate that fee
but i'm not 100 percent sure
you know so i figure so if i did have to
take one that would be towards the end
something should i just do that now
instead
you're you're asking questions i'm gonna
turn this over to anthony here but
you're asking should
questions against a math problem so you
should be able to know here's what's
gonna cost here's how much money i have
and
will or not can but we'll earn where's
the should coming in from
um no i mean based on the math i did
i will be able to graduate from that
there you go you know i'll have like 20
bucks and a t-shirt it's my name you
know like that's it but
you'll have no dignity your pride
you'll have accomplished something major
and then you'll be able to slide onto
the next step i'm gonna turn over to
anthony this is his wheelhouse i got
nothing to say
he just said exactly what it what he
said so i'm gonna i'm gonna borrow money
when i know i can become debt free
that is that is that is a dumb move
lucas
don't do it okay all right that's a dumb
move if you know you can graduate 100
debt free why do you still want to go
out there and put yourself
in debt hoping and praying that the
government will eventually come
i mean has the government not showed us
that we cannot trust them
that they are not they do not make the
right decisions when it comes to money
and so for you lucas when i'm going to
say you already have it
don't play with your life like that
don't don't put yourself
in that in that situation bro you are a
smart man you are a young man
do not make a dumb decision like that
now i ain't
when i don't want to finish the
conversation don't do it that's it you
know i hadn't considered somebody
seeing this and thinking oh
i can just go take out loans for
anything for a car
i can take them out for rent for tvs for
another semester of college because
no the government's gonna come in on a
cape with a superman logo on it and
save us yeah but that's that is a stupid
move
oh man the government said they may
forgive student loans down the road well
let me go get this money
just so in case if they do it cool great
i got free money well it's not free
money somebody's gonna pay for it
if you don't think if that's a great
point if you get your loans forgiven
there will come a moment where you
20 years down the road 30 years down the
road 10 years
or worse your kids
are gonna have to pay this back yeah
and if you can get through it if you can
work your butt off
grind scrape get through college
debt-free
do it yeah it's not worth it and then
too and i'm and i'm looking
and i'm studying i'm seeing what's out
there with this new administration
uh in the white house um and and if if
if if it does happen there are some
stipulations like community service
hours and
uh stuff like that that comes along with
this thing
so if you do not have to take it out at
all
don't even consider it even if you think
you have to
holla at me come over to my show come
over to my youtube
get my book debt free degree and we will
figure out a way to how to get you into
college 100 debt-free but do not set
yourself
up to fail because you will set yourself
up to fail let's go tonight all right
let's go to tracy in new orleans we're
going to talk about this all day and get
us all fired up
call one tracy what's going on
hi uh thank you for taking my call uh i
had a question about uh
moving and uh what should i do with an
old 401k yeah i had sitting with a
company
okay um i worked i worked for a company
for 19 years i
moved to a different job about six years
ago okay
and they've been i've had i let that
money sit there for now because i was
in a good relationship with the
financial advisors who were
uh managing the money for me and we
talked a lot but they just switched
companies
yeah don't know anything about the new
company i'm not too comfortable with yet
i wanted to be a good idea just to
i was thinking about moving it and
self-manage it from what i've learned
working with my other old financial
advisor nah nah nah
what i would do well do you still do you
have a financial advisor now
i was dealing with the guy who was at
the old company so i needed to say the
name of the company no don't worry about
it so here do this
uh what i want you to do is when you
hang out with us look up smart investor
pro go to
daveramsey.com look at one of our smart
vested pros and i want you to interview
one person or well you're going to read
five people because five people gonna
call you
and find you someone that can help you
out and what i want to do is tell them
you want to move your 401k over to a
traditional
um a traditional ira do not move it over
to a roth ira tracy because here's the
thing
you're going to pay taxes on it exactly
so move it over to a traditional 401k
and then from there just have them
advise you on what to do moving forward
but honestly i would have did this two
three years ago even if i was
comfortable with it
if comfortable with my financial advisor
i still would have moved it over
and so immediately what i'm doing uh top
of next week or monday
is i'm jumping on the phone i'm finding
me a financial advisor
i'm saying hey i want to move it over
how much money do you have in it right
now uh tracy
about 200. yeah about 200k yeah man you
need to move that on over
um and get that invested into a growth
stock mutual fund and uh
that we can go from there but absolutely
bro that's what i would do
well i do appreciate that and now i
would just want to you know
i just wonder if i should make that move
or not you know it's not a wonder if
it's just i'm just wondering when are
you gonna do it and anthony you said the
magic
t-a-x it's that time of year again folks
tax season filling your taxes is like
going to the dentist
no one wants to do it but we all have to
and i get it
they're not fun but it can be easier our
new tax filing software ramsey smart tax
is a simple
and reliable way to get your taxes taken
care of without the extra hassle
i'm doing this with me and my family's
money that's how good it is
you're doing it too i'm doing i'm using
the ramsey smart tax product so it's not
something i'm trying to pitch
that i don't use in my own house okay
prices start at 17 bucks for federal
taxes
text tax to 33789 that's
t-a-x-33789
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the dave ramsey show i'm dr john
dolone with my good friend
anthony o'neil we are taking your calls
on money and life
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
let's go to maria in tampa florida maria
what's going on
dr john anthony thank you so much for
your time
i appreciate it very much you got it
what's going on
okay so my question is regarding
behavior changes throughout the process
with that free process
i know that we've made a bunch of
positive changes my husband and i
um i'm 27 he's 34. and we found
ramsey solutions when we were homeless
living in a tent
oh wow in florida but i mean that's
that's where we were
okay and we've from that point
got gazelle intense we cash flowed into
an apartment and all of the
fixings you know the basic floor walls
and everything i have
two small daughters now my second one
was just born in july
so after stork stork mode
before my daughter was born we
we've kind of identified that both of us
are impulsive
compulsive and uh although
i'm not spending money on things that
are accruing new debt
i'm like okay there's a thousand dollars
left on this card there's a thousand
dollar emergency fund here
i can just build that back up and of
course that's like
murphy hits so i totally drained our
emergency fund
and then one thing after the other back
to the overdraft to the overdraft
and just like a gut punch to myself
and my husband like at the same time and
i'm struggling with myself for making
choices like that like am i really
evolving in a positive way are we really
taking steps forward and then just
some insight and wisdom into this whole
process because
this is it's it's a lot and it's it's
not just
money it's behavior too and so maria
i want to start this whole call off by
telling you that you're courageous and
i'm proud of you
you've walked a journey that very few
people in this country will ever
understand
from a tent to an apartment to mom to
wife
to co-creator of a future that you don't
even have a picture for
that is brave and that is hard and
anthony and i salute you
okay so how did you guys end up in a
tent
um i think the main cause being living
outside of our means we have both been
chronically underemployed
uh since we've been together we met when
i
like right before i turned 19 and
i've been a cna and i've been in a
nursing home as an assistant so i've
done
work and i'm a massage therapist and
i think that we weren't earning enough
and then we were trying to rent a house
that was just too much
and then um we did things like go on our
honeymoon on a credit card
that i'm still paying off and stuff like
that kind of
builds up so here's what i hear
i hear two people that know how to work
their butt off
they can grind it can figure it out and
you made some mistakes
with money you didn't you made some you
made some not wise decisions
so here's the thing there is a
difference between
guilt and shame you ever heard me talk
about this
i don't think so okay so i want you to
think of guilt
as a brick that you pick up
when you violate one of your core values
when you violate a
one of your ethical or moral boundaries
i think guilt can be a positive
motivator
you got to sit in it for a second and it
sucks it hurts it's annoying it's
frustrating
it makes you cry it makes people around
you go yep that was you
right and so when it becomes shame
is when you take that brick and you put
it in your purse or your backpack
and you say i'm going to carry this
forever because this is who i am
i'm always going to screw this up
i am always right when we're on the
precipice of of
getting our money stuff together i'm
always
gonna be a joke and here's the thing
maria it's hard for you to see it
as you're telling us this story i mean
anthony we're cheering you on
yeah you're an absolute rock star and
here's what you tried to do
you got so excited you got so gazelle
intense you were running so fast you
tripped
okay you tripped and you tried to do one
little thing
outside the the plan right we all have
been there
we've all done it and here's what i need
you to do i need you to forgive maria
dust yourself off and say i
i thought i was going to do the baby
steps plus one
plus maria maria steps yeah i stubbed my
toe
it's good we're back on i'm back in and
here's the thing you are going to have
to practice a series of new behaviors
because you've never done this before
and when you screw up when your husband
screws up and
uh spoiler alert he'll screw up too okay
you can be graceful with one another you
can feel that guilt because it's
appropriate and then you can put that
brick down and start running again
yeah okay and now i want you to take
that grindy hard work that hard work
that
you're working at a nursing home you're
working as a massage therapist you're
doing all these things
i want you to apply that to one or more
positions
in your area and your husband too that
pays you what you're worth
that's going to work you towards a
career that you love that's going to get
you out of this cycle
right and it's going to be a season and
it's going to be a challenge but you're
worth it and y'all can do it
and then you're gonna keep plugging away
these baby steps day after day it's
boring
not sexy not cool no fireworks but
you're gonna keep going
and then you're gonna look up and y'all
are gonna have a whole new trajectory
and i heard that little girl's voice in
your background
you're changing your family tree maria
right
yes sir right
yes is your husband all in he's all in
we're both all in that's why it's felt
like such a blow okay so are we back up
are you gonna put the brick down
totally back up backpack purse fanny
pack of bricks all down
and we're all in together yes when's the
last time you all had a date
oh my goodness uh it's been a while
all right so here's what i'm going to do
i want you to stay on the line
friday february 12th that's next friday
me and my friend rachel cruz dave
ramsey's daughter are doing a
special valentine's day date night money
and marriage event
and we're going to help couples all over
the country this thing is selling like
bananas
it's going to be a night where you can
prop your feet up get the kids to bed
early
and you can prop your feet up you all
can hold hands you can sit by each other
on the couch and we're going to talk to
you about your marriage we're talking
about your money
how to come together even closer how to
forgive one another how to grow
and then we're going to launch you off
into the next
75 of 2021 on with some tools on how to
be bare
better married and better um get
connected with your money does that
sound cool
oh my goodness thank you so much i
appreciate that hey that's on
us and listen man we are in your corner
anthony what do you what words of wisdom
yet for our friend maria i don't have
none
you did a great job yeah when you get
done with this phone call i just want to
talk to you
all right maria yes
go forth high five have a date on us and
we were looking forward to
seeing hearing your debt free scream in
a few years when you call us back
what's up anthony i'm a matt i mean
you're just giving away your event ain't
you i mean you feeling generous today
we've sold so many we had this
projection into selling and selling and
i
i am after being in the in the after
being in the meetings
i keep thinking this is an event i would
want to watch and i know that sounds
ridiculous because we're a part of it
but when i'm listening to rachel walk
through her content and when i walk
i think i want to be sitting by my wife
when this
when this when we hear this because i
want to have
this discussion together and a couple of
times anthony have gone home and said
hey sheila i'm thinking about telling
this story
and she's like there's zero percent
chance you're telling that story
that is staying at our house but there
is some things that i had to get
permission
like you know what's so funny is you're
gonna help everyone go home to have a
real good valentine's night with their
spouse yep and you're gonna go home
and you're gonna be sleeping on the
couch i'm gonna call anthony and say
listen
you got a real nice place it's
valentine's day i'm like you ain't
coming over here buddy can i stay in
your basement
no siree uh yes i am uh i won't be a no
man or no valentine's
listen uh-huh i'll stay downstairs you
should eat i'm coming to your place
forever
you should have shut up no you should
have done it ladies and gentlemen
marriage of money february 12th get your
tickets at daveramsey.com i
promise you it's going to be good i
promise
anthony you should be i'm going to give
you a code too my man i ain't going
you are i'm just going to go on your
little uh laser watch you got there your
apple
i don't know what they're called this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
let's go talk to carter in sioux falls
south dakota
carter what's going on how can we help
hey guys thanks for having me
um you've been i'm a college student um
i'm in my second year school
i'm 20 years old and i'm graduating
early next year
in may and i have 31 000
in student loan debt and i'm just
wondering how do i go about
paying off my next three semesters
counting this next summer where i don't
have to take out more student loans
all right such a great question man how
much does it cost you to go to a school
a year
um with my federal fafsa and everything
it's about two thousand dollars per
semester
all right so you have two semesters uh
um correct
three laps i have classes this summer
too all right cool so you have six
thousand dollars that you need to come
up with correct
yes are you working i am working how
many hours a week are you working
um right now i'm trying to put in 15 to
20 i'm working from like remote access
and doing stuff
for my dad because i will have a job
secured next year afterwards too
okay cool are you living at home are you
living under dorms
um i'm living in a house in my college
town
okay cool are you paying for that out of
pocket is that inside your tuition
yep that's out of pocket okay cool great
so this is what this
is you literally have the answer to your
question right there
if you're working a minimum of 15 to 20
hours if you're just doing bare minimum
wage
uh you can go ahead and cash flow that
six thousand dollars
because the average uh also tuition is
like ten thousand dollars that comes out
to about nine hundred dollars a month
so you're right around 650 675
top in of what you need to come up with
on a monthly basis to cash flow the rest
of your school experience
so if i'm you i'm sitting down and i'm
budgeting out and making sure
that between myself and my family we can
come up with top
top in seven hundred dollars a month to
cash flow the next three semesters
which is six thousand dollars real easy
real simple
very straight to the point okay
sounds good there we go appreciate you
man anthony i love it when
someone calls with the complex problem
and your response is that's not complex
you know i was watching this thing that
uh cody your uh brand manager gave me he
said dr phil
he said someone asked dr phil and said
hey man uh it was joe rogan joe we're
gonna ask dr feel like how are you you
know having these these these
you know hard conversations he said no
i'm i'm not having a hard conversation
they're asking me a hard answer and i'm
just giving them a simple
answer sometimes complicated situations
yeah but the answer is pretty simple
simple
yeah you know that's simple simple math
okay you got six thousand dollars you
got a year
two two three semesters that's a year
and a half to knock that out
yeah bro listen here that's easy do the
math break it down
break it down to per month of what you
need to do now if you would have told me
he needs
a hundred thousand dollars then okay
yeah the math doesn't make sense so now
that we need to
do something different but if all you
need is six thousand dollars
we can come up with six thousand dollars
in three semesters that's right
it's easy uh uh i love it all right
let's go to uh david
in indianapolis david what's going on
uh yeah i'm doing pretty good thanks for
taking my call
you got it man um
my question is how do i handle
collections
before they contact me
and the reason why i haven't phrased
like this is because i
have checked my credit report recently
and i have noticed
two what i believe to be medical bills
stuck in collections that i have no
recollection of and how do i
handle that debt before
i get these calls so are you saying that
that you're not aware of this debt as
far as it could be possibly
fraud or are you saying yeah i owe it
but
how do i reach out to them first what
are you saying
um i want to know how do i reach out to
them
first because i'm i'm not sure if
i'm at fault with those because it could
be fraud i'm not 100
cool so normally what happens within
collections they have 30 days so once
they acquire the account
the bill collector they have 30 days to
send you a notice
letting you know that that hey they are
collecting on this medical bill
within that time frame you have the
right to dispute any charges jump on the
phone with them and file a dispute
or you can go if it's already on your
credit report there should be a name
and a number and i would just call them
and say hey i see this on my credit
report
i'm not fully aware of this can you help
me uh
understand where this is coming from and
so i can backtrack and see if this is a
bill of fine if it is a bill of yours
uh then one of the keys not key secrets
but the key things i tell everyone when
dealing with a collection agency
don't pay within the first three weeks
in a month paid within the last five
business days of the month because bill
collectors are commission ran
um and they're they're a base salary but
they make all their money off of
commissions
and so if you want to pay them within
the last three to five business days i
mean heck
as long as you got the money you know i
for me i would wait till the last
business day of the month because
that's when they'll cut deals because
they're trying to make their commission
check um
but if you don't owe it then you're not
paying them nothing
do you need to file a dispute with your
credit repair credit report
uh file a dispute with the actual
company um and go from there but the
first thing is you need to reach out to
him david
and just say hey ma'am sir i see this i
need information so i can validate or
non-validate
on this account it's mine and then from
there you move forward whichever way you
need to move forward with
make sense yes and david
i i'm this is a
an additional question here that i must
ask him back so when you look at your
credit report
and it's got two medical debts on there
all right you have no recollection of
going to the doctor or a surgery
or some sort of uh
not to my knowledge there is a good
possible chance that i have been
i just
sometimes that stuff is not from the
last two months more than likely that
medical stuff could be
up to a year two years yeah it could be
a long time
uh from now and the hospital was trying
to collect on it
then they sold it to a outside
collection agency
so i i can't say it doesn't happen but
it's not too often
uh medical bills are fraud and so i
would lean on the sign that
side that it is yours and maybe that
your health insurance provider
didn't pick up that balance um and go
from there but the key thing is david
you know just make sure that if it is
yours take advantage of
of making them sweat a little bit and
trying to settle in full
um if you can't afford to pay for it in
full the last three to five business
days of the month
do you feel like you'll always be stuck
paying off your debt
no anthony no look at you already
answering let's see
well i've got something for you anthony
you'll if you feel like you'll never
have extra money to save or spend
i need you to know this anthony and
anybody listen it doesn't have to be
that way it's time for a new way of
thinking
hey man you have to believe you can get
rid of this and take control of your
money
because you can and it won't take nearly
as long as you think it will
with ramsay plus we'll kick off 90 days
of guided help so you can put more of
your money back in your bank account
in the ramsey plus program anthony's got
a ton of information
i've got stuff in there our friends ken
and and
chris and rachel dave everybody's got
cool stuff in there to walk alongside
you
to teach you practical ways to get small
consistent wins
that add up to big results and
better habits and that means you'll get
where you want to be
faster debt free and spending your money
without
worry this year you can make more
progress on your debt
and saving more than you ever have get
ramsey plus
and start living the life you want
faster start
ramsay plus for free text trial to 33789
that's trial two three three seven eight
nine anthony someone's thinking
what what is would somebody do in ramsey
plus
talk to him about stuff you've got in
that program
well for me man i'm actually asked
answering a lot of the most common
questions
that's what i'm doing in there um it's
because i'm just i'm taking myself back
down to
you know the average person in america
and sometimes when you get in a program
like this
financial peace university you have some
questions about this about okay
credit cards debit cards getting
financed so for me
i'm bringing solid solutions and answers
to the most common questions
and i love it so that's what i would say
i'm bringing to it
and it's amazing it changed my life and
it can change yours
remember the caliber of your future will
be determined by the choices you made
today
make the right choice and sign up for
ramsay plus this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is john 14
26
but the helper the holy spirit whom the
father will send in my name
he will teach you all things and bring
you
your remembrance all that i've said to
you
lew holt says it's not the load that
breaks you down
it's the way you carry it
it's not the load that breaks you down
it's the way you carry it
lew holtz is one of a kind man he's a
general brother
one of a kind all right let's go to
christopher in cincinnati ohio
christopher what's going on how can we
help
hey how's it going thanks for having me
you got it what's going on
hey you know my wife and i we've been
listening to your show um
here for a while now and we actually
have been fortunate enough to pay off
all of our credit card debt
uh congratulations man i appreciate that
thank you yes uh
you know it doesn't happen overnight you
know it took a few years to save up but
you know now that we have that that big
chunk saved off paid off and
um you know listening to your show you
know you guys talk about saving for a
nest egg
what is that right number to save for
nest egg and can you break that
up into like a long-term savings with
investments or would you recommend
you know saving that nest egg in cash um
we just started budgeting in january
um going forward to like track all of
our spending
and really look forward to you know
continuing to build our savings and and
just investing for a future yeah and we
just want to know what the
best move would be like should we should
we you know not to wait the student loan
debt should we notch away at the home
or should we just you know save it all
in cash
yeah good question good question so
here's the thing man we have the first
three baby steps is something that i
want you to follow in order we we don't
break these for nothing
so right now you should have a thousand
dollars in your emergency fund nest egg
right now okay
how much do you have in your nest egg
right now uh well in a in
so we have about a little uh you know as
of close of market yesterday about 5 800
in the in the market and mutual funds
we got about 3 thousand in cash okay
cool so you got three thousand dollars
in cash okay crewing got fifteen hundred
dollars in your mutual funds all right
cool great
so this means three thousand dollars in
cash now how much total
consumer debt do you have left uh left
over
excluding your mortgage
none well you just i thought you just
said you have some credit cards or
something like that student loans
student loans
oh student loans yes we have about 30
000 together
yeah yeah so consumer debt let's let me
help you out with this anytime we say
consumer debt that is anything
if you owe anybody anything that is debt
including your mortgage okay so
student loans are still debt so i want
to make sure we're clear you have
student loans you don't have any credit
cards do you or do you no
okay cool do you have a car payment
we pay them off okay cool great so so
right now you're in baby step number two
all right you're paying off all of your
student loans you're not waiting for the
government to see what they're going to
do
see if they're going to forgive if
they're going to forgive the most
they're going to forgive right now is
from what i'm seeing
if it happens about 10 to 15 000 okay
so right now you're in baby set number
two you're paying off all of this
student loans
you're not really worried about having a
bigger nest egg right now
i want you to focus on getting out of
all of your debt completely
then we're gonna go over to babysit
number three and set aside
three to six months for a fully funded
emergency fund aka
a fully funded nest egg so three to six
months of expenses
so you're gonna break down your expenses
based upon
what do you need to live you know your
mortgage payment your rent payment
your utilities your food um you name it
what do you need to live
that that's what we call expenses but
right now you're not worried about that
you're not worried about investing into
a mutual fund you're not worried about
investing to a roth ira in a 401k right
now you're sitting
in baby set number two you're gonna get
those student loans
you're gonna break it down from smallest
to largest then you're gonna be
attacking it the very
first one the smallest one putting all
of your eggs onto that one
you're gonna work the debt snowball to
that
method all right so you got 3 000
i'm taking 2 000 out putting that on top
of the 30 000 i'm down to 28
and then i'm grinding to get the 28 000
out of the way by the end of this year
then boom next year me and my wife we're
debt-free we're going to get a fully
funded emergency fund
then we're looking to purchase a home so
that's what i recommend man
and i appreciate you calling in you know
what's so funny is john um
harvard just recently came out with a
study uh saying that that
that these harvard professors you know
every now and then i i
i tend to you know disagree with them
but on this one right here they they hit
this one on the head but they hit this
one on the head
all these high-end people like you all
these doctors and
and people like you educated people uh
actually now this one on the head john
you know
every once in a while every now and
every now and then and they said that
the best way to pay off your debt is by
what
the debt snowball method not the
avalanche
avalanche method paying off highs
interest down to the smallest one
they said the best way to attack your
debt
harvard said it is the debt snowball
and they i think i think they listened
to us bro i think that's what it was it
was listening to me and dave not you
because you adopted too and it was
listening to me and dave who are not
doctors
and they heard us say that this is not a
math problem you need momentum you need
excitement psychology
you need energy you need to trick your
brain and it's i was like yo
harvard okay if i go back to school
i may consider you and then i woke up
and said i ain't going to harvest
that man sometimes
i'm sitting on the radio and anthony
just tosses me softball after softball
and you just got to let them go by
yeah i can't swing it none of them man i
mean you're the doctor you know what i'm
saying
you know so so you educated the hardest
thing listen
i spent some time at a small program for
a few weeks there at harvard can i tell
you the most frustrating part
what was it i wanted so badly anthony i
wanted
so badly for harvard to be this big
media fabrication
i was gonna get there i already had my
phd i was gonna be like man we're all
same team
same team man anthony
hey hey i wanna they're real smart
that's all i'm saying listen they were
real
smart i've never seen they're going you
know i got invited i actually
got smarter than me she's smarter than
me she's smarter see so
i just you know i don't know but you
know i'm going to say the name of the
school because i don't want to be
disrespectful and i may end up going i
don't know
but you know there was a big ivy league
school that you know offered me a full
ride okay
to finish my degree no chance that
happened but go ahead yeah no chance
that it's going to happen
zero i'm not gonna say zero i mean i may
go back i mean because i believe
education is important right but
one of the main reasons why i said no
it's because i don't want that on top of
me
you know i'm teaching young people to go
to any school that you can afford
and an ivy league school is not that
important
is it a great opportunity yes but just
because you graduate from harvard and
these other ivy league schools doesn't
make you any
it will not make you any better than
going to a community college because i
know a lot of people
who went to prestigious schools but
they're not prestigious individuals
and i know people who start off at a
community college graduated from
in-state school or went to trade school
or went to seminary school and they came
out more prestigious than people who
went to procedure schools
so i just want to put that out there you
know for all the people but i i want to
give harvard their love and their credit
i've got two doctorates if any ivy
league school wants to pay
me to get another one i'm happy to sign
up today but anthony
if any in-state school want to give me a
full ride i'll sign up today i'll put it
out there if any in-state local
in-state school in tennessee wants to
give me a full ride i'll go
any hbcu want to give me a full ride
i'll sign up to date
ivy leagues
that's where we're different all right
so hey listen that last caller had an
important
call out here and i've heard this i've
been working with college students for
years
i know you've heard this tell me you
don't continue to hear this man
i've got debt but that's not student
loans because they don't count
student loans is not debt only credit
cards and what i owe mom and maybe some
medical stuff but student loans don't
count as debts
and that's because society says that
student loans is good debt mortgages are
good debt and our philosophy here
is debt is debt we don't believe in the
term good debt or bad debt we just
believe in a term
debt is debt and the only debt we are
okay
with having is a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage but a student loan debt is
still
debt you're still paying interest it is
the number two crisis
in america right now people have a
mortgage payment but don't own any
freaking real estate
that is that is debt how is it you owe a
hundred two hundred thousand dollars
in in debt and you're saying this is not
debt no this is debt
okay so listen dad is dead his dad is
dead his dad is dead
that is that say goodbye to dad and
never see her again or see him again
however you want to phrase it i want to
i want to thank kelly
and james for quarterbacking a great
show today
anthony i want to thank kelly for giving
away all of your event tickets thank you
kelly for uh
he was working today in that area hey
join us for the marriage and money event
anthony it's always fun america thanks
for joining us have a good
good week good weekend be kind to one
another
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you